Speaker 1: Here's just the sad clip this really.
This really is sad because we've speculated
that the former president, you know, the former
guy really doesn't have normal relationships with
people and that includes his own kids. Here
is just another one of these little segments,
and it really is sad. Eric Trump was speaking at
this Reawaken America tour. And remember, Eric
Trump is not generally known as the smart one,
and the Reawakened America tour is this kind of
like and COVID denying anti-vax religious revival
type tour that goes around the country. It's the
one where that so-called comedian Jim Breuer did
his cockatoo impression that had so many of the
people in the audience in hysterics that I didn't
find very funny. But so Eric Trump spoke at one
recently, and he did the really cool thing, you
know, showing the alpha nature of everything he
called his dad, Trump, and he said that, you know,
he really loves them. And Trump said, Have a good
have a good weekend. Um, do you guys
feel bad for Eric Trump? But really,
for all of Trump's kids? Take a look.
Speaker 3: You know what, dad? There is so much
love in this room for this country and for you
and everything that you accomplish, and I speak on
behalf of every single person here. They love you.
I love you. We're proud of you. And just hold your
breath. Everybody, hold your breath.
Unidentified:
Well, thank you very much, and everybody
enjoy yourselves and have a good weekend.
Speaker 2: Kathy in Ohio soon. I'll see you
all. Oh my God. Oh my God. I mean, it's just
Speaker 1: so awkward if you've been around truly
narcissistic people. This is typical of them, and
this is typical of how they behave. But as as far
as like a parenting parenting thing is concerned,
you know, your kid says, I love you and you go,
Well, thank you very much and have a nice weekend.
It's it's sad, and imagine that that's
the one phone call Eric's allowed,
right? I mean, we don't know how often
Eric's allowed to talk to his dad.
It really gives me kind of like, Please love me,
daddy sort of vibes. And it is sad. It really
is sad. It doesn't seem as though Trump has a
normal relationship with his kids, and it's all
very strange. But it is what it is, and there's
really not too much more that we can say about it